what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the latest craziness that
just took place in the attack on Titan
story the backstory of Amir Fritz the
original Titan and the progenitor of all
the other Titans was finally revealed
but more than that the ending of the
latest chapter through everything we
thought we knew into another massive
tailspin and things will never be the
same again there is just so much to talk
about so let's get into it
if you enjoy the attack on Titan content
on this channel and you want us to keep
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest attack on titan news
and updates and finally of course this
video will contain manga spoilers we're
talking about the latest developments in
the attack on Titan manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned by the way I know from the
comments that quite a few people would
like me to publish my take on the new
attack on Titan chapters as soon as they
drop but aside from the time it
naturally takes to produce a video with
these last three attack on Titan
chapters in particular I have felt a
need to take my time and really
contemplate what happened before rushing
to write a script the chapters have kind
of left me speechless after first
reading them and it takes me a while to
organize my thoughts but I hope that
when the videos do come out you will
find them useful and entertaining and
thank you for sticking with me the title
of chapter 1 2 2 is from you 2,000 years
ago which is a direct reference and
continuation to the title of the first
chapter to you 2,000 years from now this
is addressed later on in the chapters so
I will talk about it in a little bit the
chapter starts off with a flashback of
frida teaching historia about amir fritz
in this flashback Frieda tells historian
that Amir Fritz was ladylike and a kind
girl who's always thinking of others
remember this for later because this
subtly reveals a lot including the very
warped mind state of Frida and
fritzsche / Reis royal family Frieda
tells historia that the world is full of
pain and suffering and for this reason
historian live as someone everybody
loves and someone who depends on others
and whom others can depend on Frieda is
implying that historia be like Amir
frits
she even refers to Amir by historians
former name Krista when telling the
story the more this chapter unfolds
the more messed up Freitas message -
historian becomes in hindsight we then
finally get the real backstory of Amir
and the true origins of the Titan powers
themselves we learned that Amir was a
slave one of many slaves that were
serving the ancient LD and kingdom of
that time we can assume that these
slaves were not LD ins themselves but
rather a different group of people that
the ldiots conquered unless the LD ends
enslaved the segments of their own
population like a tribe that rebelled
against them or something like that
regardless of who exactly they were the
slaves were treated terribly tortured
maimed and abused on a daily basis we
see a scene where the LDN ruler asks a
large group of slaves which of them set
a pig free apparently someone allowed a
pig to escape maybe by accident or maybe
on purpose as a form of rebellion the LD
n ruler demands that the culprit
identify himself or herself otherwise
every slave will lose an eye as
punishment a large group of slaves then
points to Amir the same short girl that
we saw in the unknown land where the
court and it resides
Amir does not protest but we are not
sure if she actually did released the
pig or if she is just covering for the
others because she doesn't want them to
suffer and she would rather sacrifice
herself the LDN ruler tells her that she
is now free and we cut to a scene of
poor little Amir running through the
woods as LDN soldiers on horseback are
hunting her for sport even using dogs to
track her at this point I am kind of
leaning towards the idea that Amir did
indeed release the pig perhaps she felt
bad for the pig and wanted to allowed to
pick a chance to be free a chance that
she herself would never have and that is
why the LDN ruler moxy Mir later by
telling her that she is free as he
proceeds to hunt her
through the woods in her attempt to get
away Amir is injured by arrows she is
bleeding from one of her eyes and she is
barely moving she stumbles upon a
massive tree with an opening at the
bottom she walks into that opening in
order to hide but there is a hole inside
the opening and she stumbles and falls
she plunges into water and it appears
that she is about to drown then suddenly
something that looks like a disembodied
spinal cord attaches itself to Amir's
back and in the next moment we see the
entire tree explode as a massive female
Titan appears Amir has turned into the
very first Titan and this Titan appears
to have all the nine powers within
itself because even though it has the
appearance of a female Titan it seems to
be the size of a colossal Titan so
presumably all the Titan powers are
currently combined into this one Ameer
Titan I have no idea what this
disembodied spinal cord thing was and I
have mixed feelings about this aspect of
the backstory was this some sort of
ancient organism that slumbered for
millions of years and then somehow
activated when it came into contact with
a mere some sort of ancient parasite
maybe or was this some type of alien
creature that crashed to earth on a
media or and waited for millions of
years to finally find a host it's this
basically the arrow from jojo's I
honestly don't know and this part of the
story felt too much like a fairy tale to
me and fairy tale vibes is not something
that I'm accustomed to when it comes to
attack on Titan
I had always predicted that the story
about the earth devil was just a myth
and that there was no real devil at all
but my think it was that Titan powers
were the result of some sort of
primitive genetic experimentation
perhaps combining human genes with the
genes of animals including massive
animals like whales and elephants and
eventually that led to the creation of a
Titan virus that only affected LD ins
however unless we get more information
about this later
it appears that Titans were created
accidentally after some mysterious and
clearly supernatural creature attached
itself to Amir the chapter then cuts to
a scene where the LDN ruler tells an
obedient Amir that she has worked well
for him just like the LD and
restorationist believed in their own
secret history books
Aamir's tightened cultivated the land
built bridges across mountains and
allowed el dia to expand dramatically we
now know that male in history was
partially wrong because there was no
deal with the devil and all that crap
about LD ins being Devils and spawn of
the devil was nothing but propaganda but
the LD n restorationist vo history
wasn't accurate either Emir wasn't a
wise and benevolent ruler of the LD
Empire she might not have been LD n at
all instead Emir was the subservient and
obedient slave of the LD n ruler and he
used her to expand el dia and to destroy
his Mar layin rivals the LD n ruler and
his followers were just as brutal and
ruthless towards the Marlins as the
Marlins are towards the audience today
so as we could have guessed there are no
good guys and bad guys here there are
two sides who want power and who want to
dominate others and historically they
were willing to do terrible things to
other people in order to achieve their
militaristic goals as a reward for her
faithful service
the ruthless LD and ruler tells him here
that he will allow her to bear his
children not because he cares about him
here at all but because he wants his
children to inherit the Titan powers so
that they could keep using titans to
dominate the world in the name of el dia
Emir Fritz was not actually Emir fritz
she became a Fritz only when she was
forced to marry the LDN ruler who bored
the fritz family name and so through
this LDN ruler and Emir the modern LD
and royal family was born Emir then had
three daughters with this LDN ruler
Maria rose and Sheena
the three walls and parodies are named
after these three daughters we then see
a panel of pregnant Emir looking very
similar to pregnant historia from
earlier on in the manga and a very clear
parallel between the two girls is being
made over and over again it really makes
you think what the Reese family might
have done - historian remained in power
and it also makes you think about what
isayama may still be planning to do -
historian before the story is over as LD
ins defeated the Marlins using the
incredible power of Amir's Titan Marlin
soldiers and officers were
before dld and Royals and made to bow to
the ruler of el dia one of those Marlin
officers then attempts to assassinate
the LDN ruler with a hidden spear but
Emir throws herself in front of the king
in order to shield him with her body the
spear manages to tear through Emir
spinal cord and as a result she actually
dies she is not able to use her titan
powers to recover the LDN ruler tells
Emir to rise no mere spear should be
able to kill her and she was born to
serve Him so she must rise but Emir does
not rise instead her consciousness finds
itself inside that unknown land where
Zeke and Aaron have found themselves in
recent chapters the land of the
coordinate back in the physical world
the LDN ruler forces Amir's three
daughters to eat their mother's remains
including presumably her spinal fluids
in order to inherit Amir's titan powers
so that they can be passed on to future
generations and so that the audience can
continue dominating the world with the
power of the Titans
in a previous video that I made back in
July of 2019 about the secret history of
attack on Titan I said that I believe
that Amir's daughters had to eat her
body in order to inherit her power and I
thought this because during the season
two anime ending we can see an image of
what looks to be three girls eating the
body of a woman with a king standing
over them it turns out that this is
indeed what happened on his deathbed the
LDN ruler tells the daughters of Emir to
have their own children eat their spines
upon their death in order to continue
passing the Titan powers on to new
generations of ldiots that is presumably
how the nine Titan shifter powers became
separate although at this point we can't
be sure why exactly they separated into
only nine instead of even more Amir's
consciousness or essence or whatever it
is
continues to faithfully build the frames
of the Titans in the unknown world but
in that moment the back story ends and
we return to Aran holding a mirror and
trying to stop her from obeying Zeke's
order Aaron says that he will put an end
to this world right now he tells him
here that she is not a slave or a god
she is just a normal person she doesn't
need to serve anyone she can choose her
on future and Aaron asks Amir to lend
him her power so that he can end all of
this right now
Zeke screams and orders Amir to obey his
command he raves about how he is
descended from royal blood and how she
must listen to him
but while Zeke is saying all of this and
acting a lot like the old ldm ruler who
enslaved Amir in the first place
Aaron tells him here that he knows that
she was the one who led him here she has
been waiting for 2,000 years for someone
for him to come and end this long cycle
of suffering this chapter all but
confirms the fact that Amir deliberately
reached out to Aaron to you 2,000 years
from now at the very beginning of the
story and now finally Aaron has found
her to you 2,000 years ago it's almost
as if Amir planned at all a plan 2,000
years in the making but what exactly
does Amir want to accomplish on that
note what exactly does Aaron want to
accomplish what kind of crazy world
ending twist is about to happen next
we then see Aamir's eyes finally open
she is crying her teeth are gritting and
then we are thrown back into the outside
world Aaron's head which had been
separated from his body begins to grow a
massive elongated spine which will
presumably allow him to reattach his
head to his body
meanwhile the walls and parodies begin
to shatter as the millions of colossal
titans finally break free Aaron is also
apparently transforming into a Titan yet
again but I predict that this will be a
completely new form of Titan a Titan
form that combines the powers of Aaron
and Amir but what happens now the
rumbling is here millions of colossal
titans have been released the walls have
been broken but what is Aaron going to
do now let's assume that Aaron can
control the millions of wall Titans and
let's assume that eren's Titan form is
now going to be even stronger thanks to
the power of Amir surely now the likes
of reiner Zeke and peak will not be a
threat to Aaron so is he going to use
the colossal titans to destroy Marlay in
the past many of us have pointed out the
similarities between
whoosh and how the attack on Titan
ending might end up being similar to the
Code Geass ending the idea was that
Aaron might end up sacrificing himself
so that everyone else can live in peace
but now at least from the looks of it
Aaron might end up being closer to Light
Yagami than to Lelouch he might decide
to destroy the world
at least all parts when he doesn't like
and then emerge from the chaos as the
god of this new world this could be
Aaron's own personal Ragnarok and only
those whom Aaron deems worthy will be
allowed to survive before I get into
Ragnarok and how Norse mythology might
provide clues for how the story of
attack on Titan might end let's address
some of the other important reveals from
this chapter and what they mean for the
story first it was revealed that a mere
died as a result of a spear severing her
spine she did not die because of any
sort of illness or curse so what was all
that stuff about the curse of him here
if he mere herself didn't die because of
any curse why do her descendants
seemingly suffer from an illness that
kills them after 13 years of possessing
one of the Titan shifter powers since we
know that Amir was a normal human before
she became a Titan so she didn't have
any supernatural powers or abilities
that made her immune to this so-called
curse the only thing that I can think of
is that having all of the powers at once
like Aamir had allows the person to live
longer with the Titan powers
this means that Aaron who currently has
three Titan powers may be capable of
living longer than the thirteen years
especially if he can consume all nine
powers at some point in the future and
become just like the original Amir and
since we're on the topic of the nine
powers why did the Titan powers split up
into nine powers specifically instead of
even more if the powers kept being
passed down why didn't they also keep
splitting what's so special about the
number nine if all these titans started
as one single power moreover how did all
LD ins gain the ability to transform
into titans especially if he Mir herself
wasn't actually LD in either but rather
a slave of the LDN ruler
and therefore probably a member of a
rival nation or tribe I understand that
the direct descendants of Amir who
consumed the spinal fluid of her and her
children would have their DNA altered
but does this mean that every single LDN
alive today is a direct descendant of
amir fritz
i understand that it's been a long time
so it's not impossible for one person to
become the common ancestor of a large
number of people but if that were the
case then what happened to all of the
audience who were not direct descendants
of amir maybe at some point all LD ins
were injected with a portion of Amir's
blood or spinal fluid in order to turn
them into stronger warriors or something
along those lines but we will still need
more information before we can say for
sure I was personally pretty confused by
the whole curse aspect and the fact that
all LD and somehow became capable of
turning into Titans but only LD ends and
no one else now let's talk about the
rumbling and where the story could be
heading from here in a previous video
about the paths I talked about all the
many references that attack on Titan
makes to Norse mythology starting from
the frost giant Amir and extending to
the Drossel tree and a ton of other
references in fact the tree in which
Amir tries to hide in and that ends up
falling and becoming a Titan is almost
certainly another direct reference to
each drasil with the rumbling finally
occurring at the end of chapter one - -
it is clear that we are heading towards
an attack on Titan version of Ragnarok
in Norse mythology Ragnarok is the
prophecy about an apocalyptic series of
events that will lead to a great war to
the deaths of many including the deaths
of the gods themselves and to natural
disasters that will destroy the entire
world but after these cataclysmic events
the world will be renewed and two human
survivors will repopulate the earth once
again so what does this mean for attack
on Titan I don't think we will literally
see everyone on earth die except for two
people but we are going to see some sort
of Ragnarok equivalent the big question
is what are Amir and Erin planning to do
certainly if you wanted to protect
paradise alone and defeat reiner peak
the Marlins who infiltrated the island
and so on Erin would not need to use the
rumbling especially now that Amir is
seemingly
on his side the fact that the rumbling
is happening means that Aaron has bigger
plans plans that might involve
destroying the entire Marlene army and
all the other armies of the world who
were plotting to invade parody's along
with Marly
but even if Aaron succeeds in doing this
and even if LD ins become dominant once
again because of the power of Amir and
the wall Titans what will happen next
Aaron doesn't want to become the new LD
and King and just do the same cruel and
brutal things that those rulers did he
wants to destroy the old world and
create a new one and a better one but
how is he going to do it is he going to
try to destroy all modern weapons and
force people to be peaceful using the
power of the Titans is he going to just
kill everyone except a select few people
that he considers worthy is he going to
do something else entirely we really
can't be sure for now but I predict that
Aaron's plan will be very different from
Zeke's because Zeke's planned to rid the
world of aliens and with them Titan
powers was pointless in my opinion we
live in a world with no Titan powers but
we still have war and suffering if they
didn't have Titans the humans of attack
on Titan would just fight using other
weapons because of gracious conversation
with Zeke in Chapter one to one it is
safe to assume that whichever path Aaron
embraces it will be a brutal one and
many will have to suffer in order for
the world to be born anew after the
rumbling after Ragnarok I also believe
that his story on historians baby are
going to play an important role in the
future of the world and I don't think
that Levi is really dead but beyond that
it's hard to make any more specific
speculations overall this was an
extremely interesting and important
chapter even though I personally wasn't
a huge fan of the way that Amir became a
Titan in the first place I wanted some
more interesting explanation for the
origins of Titan powers although we may
still get additional information in the
future let me know what you guys think
did you like this chapter and what in
the world do you think Aaron is going to
do next also do you agree with me that
the disembodied spine thing was kind of
anticlimactic or do you think it's fine
let me know down in the comments I
always love when we get a good attack on
Titan discussion going if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications feel free to follow
me on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest attack on
Titan news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings L dress on he'll
cruise Steelers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith pitied Allah beat a
karate GN Anatoly Cosette's ki and Lord
a bird and of course some massive thank
you to all of our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including ingrid ah a lola madam madam
AK makoto-kun and yuh boys Seth if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]